thank you yesterday yes we are indeed
with the Romanian Chess Federation
president Vlad Ardell Vlad first of all
Welcome to our show how does it feel you
must be proud you've seen this project
start four years ago now four years
later how do you feel about the progress
that has been
so thank you for having me
um it's an honor and a pleasure and I
feel Joy at heart that we are the fourth
time here in Bucharest it's a dream come
true we never thought initially so far
but uh here we are we've seen yesterday
an opening Gala which was amazing
um I'm just coming from the playing hole
now and it's filled with
um with kids with Young Generation uh
chess is having a momentum and
grantchester definitely helped raise
this momentum here in Romania so a big
thank you speaking of the Young
Generation we have the world champion
here for the first time in Romania we
didn't have Magnus Carlson but now we
have the England here in Bucharest how
important it is for the new generation
to see their Idols inflation balls it's
very important so we've seen yesterday
how many kids came to play the the
simultaneous game where dingly ran has
also participated and I heard feedback
so it's amazingly important I just spoke
with couple of friends who happens to be
chess instructors here in Romania and
they're just telling me they are fully
fully fully booked so they don't have
time for their weekends any much longer
because the Young Generation is just
very hungry for chess I think this is a
um a follow-up to these fantastic events
that granchester is bringing to Romania
and it's really
moving the um the community from the
from the from the ground up so it's very
important
now tell me about the challenges you've
been running the Romanian transpiration
for quite some time now what were the
biggest challenges
um taking it from where it was to where
it is right now making that progress
well I would say it's down to the team
first so um
we've created a fantastic team that
worked together now everyone knows what
they have to do and we have
responsibilities for each and every
project that was one second was
definitely getting some sponsors in
because all any project needs blood
needs money so money it's the blood
running through the project systems so
um with the foundation superbet
Foundation one United Property is now
the largest bank in Romania is coming to
the Federation so we see
um and also big telecom companies so we
see a top five top 10
big Romanian corporate coming to uh to
chess coming to Romanian Federation as
umbrella sponsors which is definitely
great so these are the two pillars on
which we we can build projects and yeah
I think we can say that we had a very
busy years very busy last year and they
started very uh in a very great momentum
this year as well we have our uh Grand
Prix festivals which are really
coming uh coming up they they bring more
and more
performance chess players in Romania so
I think it's um it's it's going on the
right track Vlad you're a player
yourself as well you're a fan person
foremost how do you feel the atmosphere
in the playing Hall ah it's fantastic I
just coming from there and it hopes that
my humble
chess skills could read uh almost four
games out of five because one played by
firuja and Wesley so it's E4 I'm a D4
player but all the other four matches I
can decode
um and then be in the game so it's a
fantastic feeling and you can you can
feel it in the air everyone appreciates
and I think grunge's story is really
welcomed here in Romania and more and
more people are following it up either
here the whole or in digital media live
Transmissions everything Vlad thank you
very much for everything you do with the
grandchester with the Romanian trans
Federation thank you for having me thank
you
thank you Christian and thank you Vlad
indeed and I